Let's go next to a chase from
New Hampshire. You're on the air.
Hi. So I actually did have a question
about that, I forgot sorry, OK, that
sorry. Actually you should pick live free from
what? Dexters. Sorry but appreciate the question.
OK. A chase from New Hampshire blacklisted.
But I mean, I'll try it. We usually I usually
don't go to anyone who doesn't have like a
real name listed, but let's try it. Let's go
to Live Free from Washington, who somehow is
already unmuted. What's going on with that?
Oh, I'm one of your mods, David. What's up?
You can admit yourself that
sounds like too much power.
It's much power. Yeah. What's going on?
Well, I wanted to ask you a question.
Sorry, James, I wanted to ask you the same
question that I asked the consul general
in from the Canadian embassy in Seattle.
Well, I can't imagine that we have the same
background and expertize. But I will try.
I want to ask what she thought of the North
American Union, if you're familiar with
the concept the North American Union, is this
between Canada, the U.S. and maybe Mexico, sir?
Well, you just cut out. Hold on. What
was that, did you say? Yes, I did.
Oh, what would be the it would
be a union. An economic union.
What exactly are the details? Would be an
economic union, in addition, in addition to
a political union, think of like the
European Union, but a more federated state,
I mean, without knowing I would the way I
would think about it would be I would want
to hear what are the parameters of the union and
what do solid economic analyzes say would be the
impact just in a vacuum? It's hard to say. It's
it's a good idea. It's a bad idea. I don't know.
Would the idea be to what would the point of it
be, would it be to negotiate in a particular way
to align wages? I mean, you know, I'm just
not sure what the what the point would be.
Well, my idea at least, would be the
utilization of transfer payments to a levelized,
like the total economic capacity of these
different regions, bring up the standard
of living in different regions, have a
larger organizational capacity to, like,
organize against other blocs of countries or
regions. Yeah, especially as we move forward.
In my general kind of idea, I would evaluate
it in the context of geopolitics, knowing with
China and Russia as the two other big superpowers
with, you know, India, Nigeria as a growing power,
I would think about it more in terms
of what it would do geopolitically from
the standpoint of American interests.
Now, if you want to say, would it be
better for Canada or Mexico, those are different
calculations. But I would want to see an economic
analysis that would look at it. What does it mean
for the United States in a geopolitical context?
Geopolitics is definitely the first lens which I
look at this through, I mean, the same thing with
TV and Tippee, you know, looking at I mean,
containing is probably the wrong word, but
utilizing trade mechanisms to limit the
expansion of China's influence and other factors.
It's completely conceivable that economists
would look at it and say that's a good idea.
I think it's basically an academic question
because you and I probably both would agree
that this isn't going to happen.
Well, it's an academic question
definitely in the next 50 years or so. But,
you know, thinking broader and beyond that,
I yeah, I would unironically call myself
a globalist and think it's a good idea.
And you're not saying you're not using
that as code for Jewish as money, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I
just mean like globalization,
right? People are laughing at me.
You're not saying I'm Jewish. You're
saying you are actually a globalist.
Yes. No, I'm saying I'm actually a global
goddess. All right. Very good. I appreciate the
call. All right. You have a good day, David.
All right. Rescuing the abortive call from
Chase from New Hampshire. That is going to do
it for today. I'm sorry. I wasn't able to get
to everybody, but we will take calls again if
I have anything to say about it. We'll take
a quick break and be right back after this.